une liste renouvelée avec des jeunes
issus de l'ensemble des quartiers de la
ville voilà les membres de l'équipe la
verrière en commun mené par nelly duthu
avec un projet politique sociale et
écologique pour les habitants en fait
sur un peu des trois quartiers à la base
je suis vraiment originaire du bois de
l'étang
gg j'ai vécu 27 ans j'ai vécu aussi à
orly parc et au village donc vraiment
j'ai vraiment une vue d'ensemble de la
ville au niveau du conseil municipal si
on peut favoriser la solidarité l'aide
de l'aide aux gens là j'essaierai de
faire mon possible
plusieurs mesures pour l'insertion
professionnelle la création d'une régie
de quartier instance dirigée par des
habitants et des élus pour développer
des services et embaucher des habitants
autres mesures pour favoriser l'emploi
obtenir un chargé de mission sur ce
domaine avec plusieurs objectifs prendre
contact avec les entreprises faire
connaître la verrière montrer à la
hausse en treprises que les ans les
jeunes ou les moins jeunes de la
verrière
on peut leur faire confiance autre point
avoir plus de produits locaux et bio
dans la restauration scolaire et à terme
l'idée d'une cuisine centrale pour
confectionner les repas des élèves de la
berrière je crois très sincèrement que
les enfants ont droit à cette cuisine
qui donne des repas de meilleure qualité
où on peut justement faire attention à
ce qu'on met dans l'assiette sur les
grands projets nelly duthu souhaite
poursuivre le projet zac gare bécane et
assurer la rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang sans destruction